[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do you have a family
you'll never know
and I have no choice
well every time you find yourself here
it's because you chose to come back
oh my friends here we are at the end of
another
22 and we welcome in 2023. we wanted to
take one final look at all the
incredible TV shows that swept the small
screens this year from welcoming
newcomers like Apple TV's premiere of
severance to saying goodbye to Old
favorites like the final season of
Atlanta the competition was fierce as we
have been blessed with a plethora of
binge-worthy TV over the course of the
year so for this list we went through
the ringer pulling together the top 10
TV series of the Year all ranked by
Tomato Meter so let's take a walk down
memory lane together with one final
hurray for the year as we count down the
best TV shows of 2022.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number 10 stranger things
Mysteries unravel in a small Midwestern
town in the 1980s involving Supernatural
forces secret experiments and one
strange girl starring Winona Ryder David
Harbor Millie Bobby Brown and created by
Matt and Ross Duffer critics say darker
and denser than its predecessors
stranger things his fourth chapter sets
the stage for the show's final season
and typically binge-worthy fashion
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning children
how are you today
[Applause]
good I'm glad to hear
because today I have something very
special planned for you
11. if you're listening
number nine Atlanta
two cousins work through the Atlanta
music scene to better their lives and
the lives of their families earn Marx is
a young manager trying to get his
cousin's career off the ground Alfred
miles is a rapper who goes by the stage
named Paperboy a hot new artist trying
to understand the line between real life
and Street Life Darius Alfred's
right-hand man and Visionary rounds out
the Entourage along with Van van is not
only ern's best friend but the mother of
his daughter Donald Glover and Brian
Tyree Henry co-star as ernan Alfred
respectively starring Brian Tyree Henry
Le Keith Stanfield zazi beats and Donald
Glover who also created this show
critics say Atlanta takes Paperboy and
his Entourage out of Georgia but this
inspired third season proves that the
more things change the more they stay
weird uh y'all got hot sauce right yes
it's uh very spicy so maybe not too much
and please open
don't let up do they what they saying
man uh they say free Paperboy
all right
man thank you bro
excuse me Mr Mouse ow man oh your bill
is being paid so you're free to go
my Builder
what's your name
phones yes phones France hey man look
I'm gonna get my lunch first all right
and um just wake me up for my nap when I
get here all right yes whatever you want
okay you turn the thermostat down a
little bit it's a little warm yeah I
appreciate that shoot up Turn Off the
Lights oh that'd be great man yeah thank
you all right see you
yeah
number eight Pachinko
based on the New York Times bestseller
the sweeping Saga Chronicles the hopes
and dreams of a Korean immigrant family
across four generations as they leave
their Homeland in an indomitable Quest
To Survive and Thrive starring yajang
Yoon minholi minha Kim and created by
Sue Hugh critics say intricate yet
intimate Pachinko is a sweeping epic
that captures the Arc of history as well
as the enduring bonds of family
foreign
foreign
number seven severance
Markley's a team of office workers whose
memories have been surgically divided
between their work and personal lives
when I'm a serious colleague appears
outside of work it begins a journey to
discover the truth about their jobs
starring Adam Scott Britt Lauer Patricia
Arquette and created by Dan Erickson
critics say audacious mysterious and
bringing fresh insight into the Perils
of corporate drudgery Severance is the
complete package here sorted the
Departments by virtue macro dads are
clever and true while Owen D's more
cruelty centered how many departments
are there probably 35. no one's quite
sure Owen D tried a violent coup on the
others decades ago and that's why they
reduced some none of two and that's why
they keep us all so far apart now that's
an absolute fiction did they ever kill
anyone nope there was no coup no one
killed anyone then why don't we ever
hang out
I mean I'm 99 sure there was no coup
they come back and attack us I think we
should kill mark
oh yeah yeah
so they think we're crazy with nothing
to lose smart that's smart like I'm
imagining them rounding a corner and
we're all blood soaked and I'm wearing
your face and they're like who's face
that and I'm like the last person with
us
and that's just feeling like a really
powerful image to me just
seems like they'd recognize my face
maybe a few words inside out
number six the boys
superheroes are often as popular as
celebrities as influential as
politicians and sometimes even as
revered as Gods but that's when they're
using their powers for good what happens
when the heroes go Rogue and start
abusing their powers when it's the
powerless against the super powerful the
boys head out on a heroic quest to
expose the truth about the seven and
Vaught the multi-billion dollar
conglomerate that manages the
superheroes and covers up their dirty
secrets based on the comic book series
of the same name starring Karl Urban
Jack Quade Anthony Starr and created by
Eric Kripke critics say managing to up
the ante on what was already one of
television's most audacious satires the
boys third season is both bracingly
visceral and wickedly smart
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
number five Better Call Saul
he wasn't always Saul Goodman Ace
Attorney for chemist turned meth dealer
Walter White six years before he begins
to represent Albuquerque's most
notorious criminal Goodman is Jimmy
McGill a small-time attorney hustling to
make a name for himself he's a forceful
Champion for his low-income clients and
Underdog whose morals and Ambitions
often Clash Jimmy works with a private
eye Mike ehrmintrot a former
Philadelphia cop and recent transplant
to the Southwest Mike is a specialized
skill set he's a fixer of sticky
situations that Jimmy soon learns to
appreciate starring Bob Odenkirk
Jonathan Banks Michael Mando and created
by Vince Gilligan and Peter gold critics
say Better Call Saul remains as
masterfully in control as Jimmy McGill
keeps insisting he's in this final
season where years of simmering
storytelling come to a scintillating
boil
thank you
detective Miss Khalil
good morning
I've been calling you for two days oh my
girl's out sick what can I do you for
tomorrow morning 10 A.M
brunch
not just you and me right I mean what
the big fella here feel like a third
wheel you and I are meeting Parson in
Chambers I am asking for an emergency
hearing to alter the terms of De
Guzman's release that sounds like a
blast unfortunately
I'm booked solid I checked your client's
place of residence the address he gave
it's a Dairy Queen in Altamonte the
family that showed at the Bale hearing
can't be located no driver's license no
tax rolls no school records nothing fact
is there isn't a single Elizabeth
McKinnon under the age of 73 living in
New Mexico
well this is this is surprising
number four reservation dogs
following the exploits of four
indigenous teenagers in rural Oklahoma
who steal Rob and Save in order to get
to the Exotic mysterious and Faraway
land of California to succeed they will
have to save enough money outmaneuver
the meth heads at the junkyard on the
edge of town and survive a turf war
against a much tougher rival gang this
first of its kind creative team tells a
story that resonates with them and their
lived experiences and invites audiences
into a surprisingly familiar and funny
world starring di Faro wunatai DeVry
Jacobs Paulina Alexis and created by
Sterling harjo and taikawatiti critics
say reservation dogs says Bittersweet
bite in its sophomore season as it mines
more difficult dilemmas than before with
its spiky sense of humor making for a
Pekin portrait of a community in place
hell sound like Mars Attacks
are you almost Spirits no man it's
mozamiko we got the same uncle
I'm gonna go get those back what kind of
gang was both red and blue Andy Mafia
couldn't make up their minds if they
want to be Bloods or Crips more maybe
they're blips well maybe they're cruds
hey
eggs for purple who are they why are
they in the village oh they're new the
founders Auntie just moved over there by
Keith's house and she fine too yeah and
they all cousins I guess some chick
named Jackie with blonde hair was the
leader of a gang in the city
and when she move here they initiated
her cousin they probably killed some
people and they've been looking for
y'all why are they looking for us
because they heard y'all with a
reservation Bandits who told them that
that's my bad see I kind of told me I
was the toughest in town and they asked
me what your gang name was and that's
all I could think of man why would you
tell them we're in a gang bro I always
wanted to be in a gang I guess they
trying to take you off the throne now
take you out to pow wow they wanted us
to join that game too but uh kind of
want to see how this plays out yo be
careful they seem serious huh we making
them
number three what we do in the shadows
based on the feature film of the same
name from Jermaine Clement and taikawa
TT what we do in the shadows is a
documentary style look into the daily or
rather nightly lives of four vampires
who've lived together for hundreds of
years in Staten Island the
self-appointed leader of the group is
nandor the Relentless a great warrior
and conqueror from the Ottoman Empire
then there's the British vampire Laszlo
a bit of a rogue and a Dandy and a fop
he might say he's a lover of mischief
and a great Soiree but not as much as he
loves seeing nandor fail miserably in
every attempt and then there's Nadja the
seductress the temptress the vampiric
Bonnie to laszlo's Clyde also cohabiting
in the vampire household is Guillermo
nandor's familiar and Colin Robinson an
energy vampire and day Walker of sorts
he feasts on humans but not on their
blood starring Matt Berry K van Novak
Natasha dimitrio and created by Jermaine
Clement critics say aside from turning
this demonic household into three
vampires and a baby what we do in the
shadows doubles down on what it does
best without drastically changing the
formula and remains fangtastic all the
same
[Music]
this is the big opening of our nightclub
we wanted the Rings to be very expensive
so then we attract Rich humans Rich
humans are basically like veal
conceptually repulsive but so battery on
my tongue I am not a creep I'm just a
very ancient warrior who wishes to marry
you
whoops cheers
[Music]
what's the word for what you guys are
polyamorous oh I was thinking filthy
hippies
[Music]
water damage is blew in the wood not
this wood I still think we should try
that old vampire freestyle rap again
gonna bust loose on the club roof
sucking throat juice like it's Gray
Goose a genie lamb I wish you to bring
back all 37 of my dead wives three
things my wife foreign
number two hacks
a dark mentorship forms between Deborah
Vance a legendary Las Vegas comic and an
entitled Outcast 25 year old comedy
writer starring Jean Smart Hannah
einbinder Carl Clemens Hopkins and
created by Paul W dowes Lucia aniello
and Jen stotsky critics say Hax hits the
road but jean smart and Hannah einbinder
remain very much at home with each other
in a sterling sophomore season that
finds novel ways to deepen the central
pair's lovable friendship
you know they're having a party for you
down there
thought you weren't drinking
what what else am I good for
we did it
we did
I did
so moving forward I can extend your
health insurance six months and offer
three months severance
haha funny
wait
what you're not serious
I am
yeah all right you're firing me
are you kidding
why things are good things are good
and they could keep being good for a
very long time that's the problem I need
to make space for your own work come on
I know what you're doing you're pushing
me away because you're afraid
euphoria
an American adaptation of the Israeli
show of the same name Euphoria follows a
troubled life of 17 year old brew a drug
addict fresh from rehab with no plans to
stay clean circling in Rue's orbit are
Jewels a transgender girl searching for
where she belongs Nate a jock whose
anger issues mask sexual insecurities
Chris a football star who finds the
adjustment from high school to college
harder than expected Cassie whose sexual
history continues to dog her and Cat a
body conscious teen exploring her
sexuality as the classmates struggle to
make sense of their Futures the series
tackles the teenage landscape of
substance enhanced parties and
anxiety-ridden day-to-day life with
empathy and Candor starring Zendaya
Hunter Schaefer Angus Cloud Sydney
Sweeney and created by Sam Levinson
critics say as willfully provocative as
ever in its second season Euphoria still
isn't for all tastes but when its
addictive ingredients are mixed just
right the results remain intoxicating
my account
wait are you in the play
I'm On Fire Let's Play what do you mean
Lexi's play uh to play that Lexi wrote
Oklahoma what a place called Oklahoma no
the drama club's doing Oklahoma
oh my god do I look like I'm in Oklahoma
why would your play be set in Oklahoma
you thought I was auditioning for
Oklahoma I haven't read it so are you
making fun of me or did you actually
think I was auditioning for Oklahoma why
the [ __ ] would you audition for Oklahoma
I'm not then why do you look like you're
auditioning for Oklahoma through what
yes
the Lord of the Rings the rings of power
this epic drama said thousands of years
before the events of J.R.R tolkien's The
Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings and
we'll take viewers back to an era in
which great Powers were forged kingdoms
Rose to glory and felt ruined unlikely
Heroes were tested hope hung by the
finest of threads and the greatest
villain that ever flowed from tolkien's
pen threatened to cover all the world in
darkness beginning at a time of relative
peace the series follows an ensemble
cast of characters both familiar and new
as they confront the long-feared
re-emergence of evil to Middle Earth
from the darkest steps of the Misty
Mountains to The Majestic Forest of the
elf capital of London to the
breathtaking Island Kingdom of numenor
to the furthest reaches of the map these
kingdoms and characters will carve out
legacies that live on long after they
are gone starring Robert arameo markella
Kavanaugh Joseph Maul and created by JD
Payne and Patrick McKay critics say it
may not yet be the one show to rule them
all but the rings of power enchants with
its opulent presentation and a deeply
felt rendering of Middle Earth
[Music]
[Music]
House of the Dragon
the reign of House Targaryen begins with
this prequel to popular HBO series Game
of Thrones based on George R.R Martin's
Fire and Blood House of the Dragon is
sent nearly 200 years before the events
of Game of Thrones telling the story of
the Targaryen civil war with King
viserys targaryens children battling for
control of the Iron Throne starring Emma
Darcy Patty considine Matt Smith Olivia
Cook and created by Ryan Condell and
George R.R Martin critics say covering
an era of tenuous peace with ferocious
albeit abbreviated Focus House of the
Dragon is an impressive prequel that
exemplifies the court Intrigue that
distinguished its predecessor
foreign
and finally number one Barry
disillusioned at the thought of taking
down another Mark depressed low-level
Hitman Barry Bergman seeks a way out
when the midwesterner reluctantly
travels to Los Angeles to execute a hit
on an actor who is betting a mobster's
wife little does Barry know that the
City of Angels may be his Sanctuary he
follows his Target into acting class and
ends up instantly drawn to the community
of eager hopefuls especially dedicated
student Sally who becomes the object of
his affection while Barry wants to start
a new life as an actor his Handler Fuchs
has other ideas and hitman's criminal
pass won't let him walk away so easily
starring Stephen Root Henry Winkler and
Bill Hader who also created the show
with Alec Berg critics say Bill Hader
and Company can take a well-deserved bow
Barry makes its belated return to the
screen without missing a step retaining
its Edge as one of television's funniest
and most unsettling offerings
thank you
hold up hold up
there you go I think we're gonna call
this off
what no eyelids just shoot him no I I
don't want him dead thank you
I thought you said you want to watch him
suffer I know but um
he's asked for my forgiveness you know
he made some valid points so uh I'm
forgiving Jeff
you're forgiving Jeff
sorry
my wife
and she's
okay there's
we don't need to get into I I think I
just overreacted well my friends that
about does it for us be sure to stay
tuned to the Rotten Tomatoes channel for
more of that entertainment content you
love until next time I am your host Naz
Perez and we'll see you back here for
more top tens on the Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]